After spending a few years in Korea,...
...I found many Korean citizens trying to make a killing on the stock market.
In fact, they are very much into making a lot of money,...
...which also causes some bad social problems and incidents.
I went to a bookstore the other day,...
...and I realized there are many books published on making a lot of money instantly,...
...or how to grow their funds.
Are you also interested in financial technology securities or becoming rich?
If you are, is it because you are jealous of people who are rich?
Well, it would be a lie if I said no...
...I'm interested in making a lot of money.
Most people, generally speaking, are jealous of people who are wealthy,...
...but at the same time, they envy the wealth too.
The feeling of envy comes when ordinary people...
...look at millionaires or billionaires.
Their fortune sounds quite unrealistic.
Let's hear from you,...
...are you jealous of Jack Welch or Bill Gates?
I bet you feel envious.
True.
I read books about them so I can grasp their strategies or beliefs.
In doing so, I wish I could be like them one day.
I don't know about how to be super rich,...
...or what makes a person rich,...
...but what I do know...
...is that being wealthy doesn't necessarily mean having incredible amounts of money.
In fact,...
...as long as you can afford your needs and wants,...
...then that means you are rich.